I started Tik tocking in like November
um because I got that bored you know
nobody believes that I'm Jim Carrey's
daughter until I do this so M it all
righty then that was my first thing I
was just like I'm just going to pretend
to be his daughter to with people
and in case I don't see you good
afternoon good evening and good
night
since Ace vura came out the minute it
came out I could just do the face you
know a lot of people will see me in
public and be like you don't look like
him but then if I do the whole yeah it's
just that and then you can always add
Dramatics the head cup the head cup
people really thought that Jim Carrey
was a dead be dad so I had to like be
like just kidding I don't want to get
sued